deutschlands innenstädte werden im
moment normalverdiener frei reden wir
drüber mit monika gruber vom vde kh dem
verband der extrem klischeehaft
dargestellt und hausbesitzer frau gruber
so kann es doch nicht weitergehen kann
es ja wirklich es ist ja auch eine
entwicklung manchmal wird ein stadtteil
leben reicher und schöner aber viele
bewohner bleiben arm und hässlich das
passwort vom style ja nicht mehr
zusammen ich sage mal zur pasta mit
trüffeln dass sie auch keine fanta oder
jetzt aber erst beispiel dann sage ich
auch zu meinem metern seid ihr wirklich
noch der tipp für münchen oder doch eher
sachsen anhalt nur mal so als gedanke
geht es gar nicht bis mind doch ich
fürchte schon die münchner
durchschnittsmiete ist in den letzten 22
jahren um 70 prozent angestiegen
die einkommen der haushalte aber nur um
34 prozent
ja ja viele münchner fahrzeuges leider
deutlich mehr geld zu verdienen
bei steht in meiner straße in münchen
haidhausen also das ist jetzt wirklich
meine straße die gehört mir da habe ich
tatsächlich ein paar echte problem mit
also ich will jetzt dann niemand
namentlich an den pranger stellen aber
es ist vor allem die familie huber
hausnummer 12 dritter stock er lehrer
sie krankenschwester und die kinder
verdienen gar nichts dazu ob die zeit
nicht den haidhausen und die haben
wahrscheinlich noch eine bestands miete
doch leider manchmal denkt man die ddr
hat doch gewonnen
zum glück gibt's ein paar tricks um
solche leute loszuwerden stichwort
modernisieren
ich lass sie jetzt im winter alle
fenster aus arm und west die neuen
geliefert werden beides kann schon mal
mit dabei werden
also letztlich letztlich zugute
nein notwehr so was hier zum beispiel
ist völlig legal wochen lang wird ihr
bad renoviert keine dusche keine
toilette als ersatz bekommen sie einen
camping klo im flur wo tagsüber
handwerker arbeiten ja da gibt jeder
auch wenn man sich das chemie kloten
muss mit handwerker die sich schon in
der früh den ersten rs gefeuert opfern
zweiten und das beste ich kann elf
prozent der modernisierungskosten auf
die miete krachern unabhängig von der
ausgangs meter wie und der eigentümer
bestimmt ganz allein etwas modernisiert
wird magna modernisierung und das kann
ja alles möglich sein
der vermieter kündigt weitere
modernisierungen an wie den einbau einer
video gegensprechanlage und eines
aufzugs damit steigt die miete von
bisher 6 145 euro auf fast 3.000 euro
[Musik]
billy regal abgebaut hat dann werdet ihr
merken wie schön
münchen ohne asoziale ist da fällt mir
ein gutes wenn ihr das jetzt hört
elendiglich luft weg aber ich kann euch
auch jederzeit das abbauen lassen die
arm rüberziehen ruhe das ja furchtbar
na gut dann wenn du dich eben an die
rentnerin therese winkel muss er im
fünften stock käfer und seit hitler da
merkliche ertragen nicht monika gruber
meine damen und herren vielen dank